hey guys it's Justine and today we are
going to try to find the iPhone from the
future I love looking at rumors and
leaks and seeing renders of phones that
we might see in the future but today
we're going to get a little bit of
assistance from AI I've been obsessed
with AI generative images so much that I
started an Instagram account called
iJustine AI to share some of those there
and also some stories that are written
by AI so it's been really fun to kind of
explore this whole new side of creation
but today we're gonna make it create us
a futuristic iPhone to get started I
actually have mid-journey installed on
my Discord server and I'm just in here
in a little private chat so that I'm not
spamming my entire Discord server but
we're going to start by entering a
prompt so what mid-journey does is it
allows you to take text prompts and it
turns them into images you can be as
vague as you want or you can be super
descriptive and each time you will get
something new so right here we're gonna
do a prompt of iPhone from the year 20.
50.
okay here it is it's happening you can
see it says zero percent so it'll start
out giving you sort of a blurry image
and then as it progresses the image gets
clear and you can see more detail so
here's our first attempt these all kind
of look pretty basic I don't really
think and I mean they definitely look
futuristic but I'm not really a fan of
any of these so I'm gonna try to give it
a more specific prompt
[Music]
draw realistic okay okay we'll see what
we get oh look at these okay so now
we're starting to get in the groove now
what's really cool about this is I can
go in and if I like any of these I can
do an upscale so I'm going to upscale
the first one I also really like this
fourth one so I'm going to upscale that
one and I'm kind of into this fourth
version like this is kind of along the
lines of what I'm thinking so I'm going
to do a variation of number four and
this will give you another output of
variations of that fourth one one day
this is all gonna happen so quickly
We're not gonna have to sit here and
wait but right now the biggest
complaints is this is taking so long
it's creating images out of nothing
let's be patient all right here's the
renders of that fourth one the iPhone of
the future freaking has Touch ID that's
really cool not really sure how it works
this one looks kind of cool it's like
the water background just sort of
expanded it's like a mini fish tank I
think this one still might be my
favorite because that looks cool okay
let's imagine cyberpunk iPhone that
connects to the human body let's see
what we get is this my future so this is
where things can get a little skewed it
took my prompt very literally this made
a body on the iPhone I wanted a human
body that's attached to the person so
this is this is not what I had in mind
but that's okay okay how can I rephrase
this this is the hardest part about AI
generative art is trying to get it to
understand what you have in your mind
imagine an iPhone that is connected to
your brain let's see what we get here
like I'm picturing you take the phone
and then you just sort of put it in the
side of your arm like a dock so let's
see if I imagine
iPhone that docks into
your what is this a forearm is this a
bicep that's right is that tricep an
iPhone that docs into your tricep okay I
filmed that box into your chest like
Iron Man uh this has an iPhone with a
brain on top of it okay so I need to
rethink some things oh man okay this
also is not what I it's not what I meant
this is my problem communication this is
not what I wanted imagine a human body
a human body that is hanging from an
iPhone with
wires iPhone implanted in the shoulder
we're getting there we're getting there
I might upskill the first one so this is
almost what I had in mind oh this one's
cool check this out oh wow
that's just an Ironman iPhone that's
sick that needs to that needs to happen
okay I think that I'm gonna go back to
my original prompts and quit trying to
implant the phone into a human body
because clearly they don't like it let's
do imagine a cyberpunk iPhone with
airplane wings
wow this is not what I had in mind but
these look so cool look how pretty
I love this third one I love the fourth
one I'm actually super into this Iron
Man iPhone like that's pretty great
let's see what should we imagine now
iPhone in the zombie
apocalypse
is this if zombies had iPhones and they
were taking pictures and selfies I think
what we're gonna do now is I'm actually
gonna ask AI write me a prompt to get
mid journey to make a future
your stick iPhone I keep spelling
futuristic and like all of these words
wrong oh this is great okay we're gonna
use some of these like these are way
more in depth than than I was doing this
is a long prompt
so here it is I'm not really sure what
any of this stuff is to be honest with
you
um this is the new feature for the
iPhone that will revolutionize the
smartphone industry
now these words make nothing make sense
a huge iPhone that is the size of a
person while that's working let's see
imagine futuristic iPhone with
transparent gloss back Diamond cameras
no ports we'll see what happens so
here's the huge iPhone that is the size
of a person that's interesting and
strange and just weird this one looks
like she's at a gymnasium this guy looks
like he just walked out of the Apple
Store and stole this phone with his
massive hand these are weird here's our
futuristic iPhone with transparent glass
back and Diamond camera
oh check this out Discord is not
correcting my spelling I'm literally
spelling every word wrong
an alien species that is made of
50 iPhone
what okay I'm gonna have to say that
this is I don't see a single bit of
human in this at all do you see a human
in there it's really cool
a human that is actually an iPhone
that's me so bad okay here it is
really confused I think we're all a
little confused as to what's Happening
Here we just don't know okay an iPhone
made of diamonds this looks hideous this
looks like one of those like two dollar
cases that I got off of Amazon this like
next prompt transparent iPhone with rose
gold trimmings a camera that is the size
of a telescope and I Wheels okay this is
so exciting because I think this might
actually be my favorite one look at this
I was thinking of Wheels as in like you
could drive it like a vehicle but this
took it and it has like Wheels on the
internals this is pretty sick all of
these actually look incredible I'm gonna
upscale all four of these because those
are so good and this last prompt that I
just kind of randomly threw in there was
an iPhone as a car I mean
it took it quite little
is actually really cool I like that
third one that might actually be a
future prompt on my AI Instagram account
speaking of my AI accounts now I need to
choose one of these images and have ai
write me a story about it so let's go
into edge here writes me a story about
an iPhone from the future it is
transparent rose gold trimmings huge
telescopic
camera and connects to your brain let's
go oh look at this this is a whole story
she held the iPhone 14 in her hand
admiring its Sleek design and rose gold
trimmings the film was transparent
except for the Apple logo and the huge
telescopic camera that protruded from
the back she tapped the screen and felt
a slight tingling in her brain the phone
connected to her neural network and
displayed a holographic interface in
front of her eyes she smiled and swiped
through her apps this is great I'm gonna
work on an image of the girl getting a
holographic image in front of her eyes
okay let's see what this will see we get
oh
these are pretty cool I'm definitely
into number four there we have it well
guys thank you so much for watching let
me know what you guys think of some of
these image renders if you guys are
mid-journey Pros I would love to hear
from you what prompts you think I should
try out if you'd like to see me do this
again I would love to because this is
actually so much fun and I'm obsessed
with AI so with that my friends I will
see you guys in my next video don't
forget to like comment and subscribe and
I'll see you in the next one bye
oh
[Music]
foreign